ravi de vous retrouver sur public sénat
à suivre cet après-midi sur un trentaine
à les travaux de la commission d'
enquête sénatoriale sur le dopage
la semaine dernière les sénateurs ont
poursuivi leur audition avec notamment
l'audition de bernard lapasset le
président de l'irb et auditions que je
vous propose de suivre tout de suite et
nous commençons nous soumission du
mercredi 7 avril en recevant monsieur
bernard lapasset président de
l'international rugby board vice
président du comité national olympique
et sportif français
je me dois en qualité de président de
rappeler les règles qui s'imposent à
nous celles et ceux qui ont décidé de
venir assister à ces auditions cet après
midi j'ai indiqué à ceux qui sont dans
le public
l'impossibilité qu'il y as pour ces
personnes de manifester l'approbation ou
la désapprobation sur ce qu'ils
entendent et la seconde chose
pardonnez-moi le formalisme c'est ainsi
que nous procédons c'est de demander à
monsieur la passe et de dire la vérité
toute la vérité devait la main droite à
dire je jure merci beaucoup
nous allons vous demander de bien
vouloir si vous le souhaitez nous dire
quelques mots
lancement de notre rencontre en nous
faisant part en dix minutes un quart
d'heure vingt minutes c'est pas quand à
mes traits à ce point de l'ensemble des
choses que vous souhaitez nous indiquait
sur cette importante question de la
lutte contre le dopage
nous procéderons ensuite nous les
membres de la commission un certain
nombre d'interrogations nous poserons un
certain nombre de questions et vous
aurez tout loisir de répondre comme bon
vous semble
aux questions que nous vous poserons
donc je commence par le commencement
je vous donne la parole pour une période
relativement brève qui vous laissera
expliquer ce que vous avez envie de nous
expliquer vous avez la parole merci
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
d'abord pour vous remercier de me
permettre d'évoquer un petit peu ces
questions devant vous sur le dopage et
les contrôles antidopage que l'on met en
place qui sont mises en place 20 ans
depuis pas mal de temps
et puis et puis c'est l'occasion de
m'exprimer en tant que non plus
président de la fédération française de
rugby mais au niveau de la fédération
internationale puisque depuis une
dernière audition que j'avais fait ici
je ne sais plus dans lequel sur autant
citer
j'ai donc changé de fonction et occupe
aujourd'hui une fonction internationale
qui me mettre de voir un petit peu les
dimensions posée au niveau de la
fédération que je représente affaires
sont des nations de rugby que je
représente ici j'ai envie de dire que
bon c'est si aujourd'hui il ya deux
trois éléments je voudrais donner en
comme entrée en matière le premier
élément c'est que
d'abord au niveau international le rôle
qu'a joué la france pendant une longue
période sur la mise en place des
contrôles antidopage et des systèmes qui
préside aujourd'hui à contrôle
antidopage notamment l'action qui a été
menée par madame marie george buffet
poursuivi par jean françois lamour très
directement ont été des éléments
extrêmement importants qui sont toujours
aujourd'hui des éléments reconnus par
les sports internationaux et notamment
par la fédération nationale de rugby
le rôle qu'a joué la france est un rôle
moteur et un rôle déterminant et je
crois que c'est c'est un élément
important qu'il faut qu'ils
considéraient encore aujourd'hui parce
qu'il a toujours un rôle à jouer dans la
façon dont on aborde des sujets
d'antidopage au niveau international la
france est encore aujourd'hui un peu
isolé dans le secteur international il
faut le reconnaître on n'a
malheureusement pas un soutien aussi
fort qu'on pourrait qu'on pourrait le
croire qu'on pourrait l'estimer le rôle
que joue la france doit être poursuivie
pour pouvoir continuer à peser sur les
orientations qui sont celles qu'on doit
avoir en matière de lutte contre le
dopage
ça c'est le premier élément qu'il faut
prendre en considération parce que c'est
un élément sur lequel beaucoup de
fédérations qui n'ont pas les moyens
qu'à la france de pouvoir agir au niveau
de sa représentation internationale
attendent beaucoup beaucoup de pays
attendent que la france s'exprime
toujours sa voix continuent à exprimer
ses positions pour pouvoir garder une
solidité sur les systèmes que ces pays
mettent en place
au travers lors il ya travers leur
fédération donc ça c'est un point
important sur lequel je voulais d'abord
faire par un petit peu de la façon dont
dans les luttes anti dopage est perçu
dans sa connotation française encore
aujourd'hui le deuxième élément que je
voudrais aborder c'est que on est dans
une situation d'antidopage où le dopage
ou le les acteurs sont plutôt
aujourd'hui en situation d'opposition
plutôt que de partenariats
je m'explique c'est quelque chose qu'il
faut bien prendre en compte la
présidente on aborde la lutte contre le
dopage pour une fédération à doper 4
dopage c'est une c'est une sanction
lourde grave c'est un acte qui met en
fédération en position difficile a
besoin de se justifier il a besoin de
trouver des arguments on a besoin
d'expliquer pourquoi comment même si
c'est s'est pas directement la
fédération qui est concerné c'est un
joueur qui est concerné c'est un athlète
qui est concerné mais la fédération se
sont en situation de pouvoir de devoir
exprimer des regrets et des remords voir
avouer ses fautes
l'absence de contrôle absent de de ceci
ou de cela donc le rapport au dopage est
toujours une crainte et le rapport au
sud de la fédération vis-à-vis des
systèmes de contrôle est toujours vécue
comme une comme quelque chose
d'extrêmement négatif le contrôle arrive
ya quelque chose qui se crée ya un
climat de tension qui se créent et
beaucoup de fédérations ceux se sentant
situation d'inconfort vis-à-vis des
contrôles qui sont effectuées sans
attendre le résultat de ces contrôles
mais déjà le seul contrôle est effectué
par contre au niveau des instances de
contrôle que ce soit la marque ce soit
les les agences nationales doivent au
contraire une recherche de da profonde
de victoire la limite
mottin peu excessif mais une recherche
de cas positifs pour influer sur le rôle
que c'est que cette agence joue que ces
agences jouent dans leur action contre
le dopage ya donc
une rivalité qui se crée où on a
toujours le sentiment qu'il ya d'un côté
des agences et des services de la main
qui interviennent pour faire leur
travail pour défendre ses intérêts pas
forcément leur intérêt mais l'intérêt du
sport l'intérêt de la mission qu'ils
reçoivent pour veiller à l'application
des règles de contrôle antidopage de
façon à pouvoir exercer cette se
contrôler de façon efficace et montrer
les services qui peuvent rendre au sport
il ya un côté positif dans leurs actions
alors que du côté des confédérations
s'est toujours vécu de façon extrêmement
contraignant et comme un élément pesant
lourd et est difficilement acceptable
ce climat est peut-être pas général à
toutes les fédérations mais qui existent
au niveau des fédérations qui est
exacerbée dans cyclisme on l'a vu
pendant des années des rapports
extrêmement difficile entre les systèmes
de contrôle et la fédération
internationale de cyclisme il existe
encore alors au rugby pas forcément
peut-être pas dans tous les pays mais
dans certains pays ou i donc diakhao ya
quand même encore ce sentiment où l'on
ne travaille pas sur un même niveau de
référence
il ya quelque part quelque chose qui
manque dans ce système dans lequel on
vit aujourd'hui où la façon d'aborder le
contrôle du dopage n'est pas vécue n'est
pas perçu n'ai pas reçu le message n'est
pas reçu de la même façon n'a pas les
mêmes on n'a pas les mêmes intentions
qui permet de rapprocher les points de
vue de rapprocher les les
les organismes qui interviennent sur
c'est sur ces facteurs-là et qui n'ont
pas forcément en finale comme des
raisins le sentiment d'appartenance au
même combat
et il ya quelque part une distorsion
entre les acteurs qui interviennent dans
le débat de l'antidopage
et ça c'est permanence est quasiment
permanent il ya quelque chose qui est
vraiment permanent et qu'on doit
vraiment analyser pour savoir comment
comment on peut essayer de travailler
pour que l'on sache bien se mettre en
situation de travailler ensemble et que
le lien entre les fédérations et leurs
athlètes et leur coeur et leurs clubs et
leurs athlètes
eh bien il doit être assuré de façon
pérenne sur des systèmes de
communication de formation
je reviendrai là dessus ce que je crois
que les éléments de formation il est
capital et même chose sur le plan des
agences on doit travailler sur leurs
liaisons avec les fédérations de façon à
pouvoir aborder ce thème de de référence
en terme de formation et de
communication qui soit adaptée à la
façon dont les gens vivent ce système de
contrôle du dopage or je ne dis pas
qu'il faille et qu'ils faillent
véritablement rentrer dans un système où
on est très heureux lorsqu'il ya des cas
de dopage positif s'est pas laissée
passer par ce système là mais qu'on soit
conscient que le rôle de chacun doit
être déterminée et que dans ce rôle là
il y avait véritablement une nécessaire
concertation beaucoup plus importante
beaucoup plus fouillée beaucoup plus
élaborée qui permet de rassembler les
acteurs du même côté de la barrière quoi
et qui est pas le sentiment qu'on se
compte qu'on attache pour ce forcément
des des conflits derrière ceux d'air ce
type d'activité on voit là les deux les
deux éléments majeurs que je ressens
concernant le rugby bonjour j viens je
crois pas que rapidement on est on a
signé la le code mondial 2002
d'antidopage en 2003 on était une
fédération qui est dès le départ s'est
inscrite dans le contrôle antidopage en
a vraiment travaillé deux années avant
que je sois moi-même président on a un
service à une commission d'antidopage
qui est présidée par aujourd'hui par
giancarlo dondi qui est un ancien
président de la fédération italienne de
rugby qui était membre du coni qui était
président de la commission antidopage au
comique qui connaît bien ses sujets qui
a mis kiaka vraiment une très bonne
connaissance des dossiers qui intervient
de façon extrêmement pertinente dans la
conduite de nos deux noms de nos
stratégies
on a donc un salon d'outils on a un site
internet dédié un site sur lequel vous
invite à lire et si vous voulez c'est
équipe de rugby clean points comme c'est
cet incident
régulier comme sur lequel on intervient
qui est en trois langues français
anglais espagnol
on développe certaines certains sujets
en différentes langues pour aborder un
peu la reconnaissance de notre système
sur d'autres territoires
on a on a un système de stratégie
permanente qui devrait a permis depuis
depuis 2003 de faire un certain nombre
de contrôles important juste un chiffre
en 2012 on a effectué 1542 contrôle hors
compétition hors compétition dont 359
contrôles sanguins puisqu'on est une
fédération internationale aujourd'hui
qui pratiquons les contrôles sanguins
depuis de nombreuses années pour faire
des recherches beaucoup plus approfondie
sur le système de contrôle antidopage
tel que nous l'avons tels que nous avons
installé
donc on est bien évidemment sur toutes
les grandes compétitions internationales
depuis les seniors avec la coupe du
monde de rugby bien sûr jusqu aux plus
jeunes avec les compétitions des moins
de 18 ans des moins de 19 ans les moins
de 20 ans on est vraiment dans des
contrôles permanents à deux disciplines
le 15 et 2 7 qui seront les deux
disciplines majeures et on a un
programme qui est aujourd'hui destiné à
toutes les fédérations nationales en à
117 fédération nationale qui se manque
de lits rb et sur ses 117 nationaux
fédération nationale
malheureusement on en a très peu qui ont
la possibilité conduit la possibilité de
créer des systèmes de deux contrôles
antidopage nationaux on a 10 et ça c'est
un c'est un vrai problème que nous avons
n'y a pas un travail c'est ce que je
viens de tout à l'heure c'est pas
malheureusement une situation très très
très efficace il n'y a pas cette volonté
exprimée par d'autres gouvernements pour
soutenir efficacement aux côtés de leur
fédération
puisque nous sommes qu'une fédération
parmi les nombreuses fédérations qui
existe aujourd'hui dans les pays majeurs
de 2,7 de la planète sportive mais il
n'ya pas malheureusement des outils
nécessaires pour qu'on soit efficace sur
le plan des des configurations plus
large de moyens d'action qu'on pourrait
mettre donc voilà c'est le président
tracé rapidement les quelques quelques
éléments je voulais apporter la
connaissance de la commission
merci pour cette introduction vous avez
évoqué dans vos propos liminaire une
question que j'aurais pu vous poser mais
vous avez commencé à y répondre donc
elle n'est peut-être pas indispensable
concernait la répartition des pouvoirs
entre les fédérations internationales et
agences nationales de contrôle
antidopage mais est peut-être une
question consécutive à vous poser est il
facile pour une fédération
internationale de lancer des contrôles
sur des joueurs très emblématique pour
le rugby ça pose aucun problème sur le
rugby ya vraiment une chose qui est
vraiment établie c'est là la possibilité
donnée la fédération internationale
d'intervenir quel que soit le joueur
quelle que soit la compétition quel que
soit le moment de l'année dans lequel on
établit un contrôle il a absolument
aucun aucune difficulté majeure même
aucune fuite aucune difficulté que nous
ayons rencontrée pour effectuer telle
qu'elle contrôle sur tel ou tel joueur
on a vraiment de ce côté là à ma
connaissance puisque je suis président
depuis 2008
mais même dans passé récent parce que
j'étais membre du conseil de l'irb et
depuis depuis quelques années depuis une
quinzaine d'années j'ai jamais eu
connaissance d'éléments qui auraient qu
aurait pu intervenir sur des noms
contrôle pour la notoriété de telles que
joueur dans telle ou telle circonstance
ça ne s'est jamais
arrivé au prolongement de cette première
question
un second point que je souhaiterais vous
qu'avec vous avez vous vu déjà des
demandes émanant de certaines nations
pour limiter les contrôles antidopage ou
bien pour ne pas sanctionner un sportif
estimez vous qu'il est difficile
d'évoquer la question du dopage dans le
rugby
alors première question non je n'ai pas
eu connaissance de deux sujets manar de
certaines unions certaines fédérations
je sais que le débat a eu lieu avant que
j'arrive mois la présidence de l'irb et
puisque lorsque les premiers systèmes se
sont mis en place à l'initiative de la
france
il ya eu des prises de positions de
certaines fédérations qui ont été
dubitatif sur à la fois la nécessité de
le faire comme l'efficacité de l'action
donc il y avait à la fois les deux
éléments ce qu'il faut c'est être
nécessaire de faire des contrôles de
dopage pourquoi et pour quelles raisons
et cetera donc il ya eu vraiment des
beaucoup d'explications qu'il a fallu
donner
et puis sur l'efficacité des moyens
lorsqu'on a créé le système de l'ama
tout le monde ya vu une espèce de deux
organisations internationales démesuré
pour les résultats qu'on pouvait en
attendre sur des moyens comme pouvait y
mettre sur l'efficacité qu'on pouvait
attendre de ces résultats et c'est donc
vraiment quelques fédérations qui ont
mis quelques doutes sur la façon
peut-être parce que ça revenait de la
france faut pas se cacher que moi je
vais dans une fédération qui est 80%
britannique et que pour domaine qui nous
concerne la france a été le précurseur
plutôt que les britanniques n'ont été
donc ça a été vraiment un élément un peu
de dépit certainement même s'il y avait
dans certains pays certainement un
problème qui se posait en termes de
moyens financiers certains ont vu tout
de suite
le fait que ça allait coûter beaucoup
d'argent que ça allait vraiment coûté
beaucoup on nomme en montant en capacité
d'organisation et que certains se
voyaient ne voyez pas le nom de la façon
dont on pouvait apporter cette aborder
ces sujets sans avoir véritablement un
aperçu beaucoup plus précis de la façon
dont on pouvait procéder dans les rues
cette période là qui a existé elle n'y a
plus aujourd'hui tous les contours sont
amis ont fait des compétitions partout
dans le monde on fait des compétitions à
fidji tonga samoa ont fait l'afrique du
sud en angleterre nouvelle zélande ne
sont majeurs on en fait sur tous les
continents
on est maintenant à l'asie on a la coupe
du monde 2019 à tokyo au japon à tokyo
enfin au japon puisque y aura dix des
dix stades en fait 2019
on ne la couvre de rugby à 7 à moscou au
mois de juin dont jour de nouveaux
territoires pour aller partout et
partout on on impose aux marques le
territoire sur les contrôles antidopage
dont n'y a pas de territoire interdit
il n'y a pas de fédération interdite il
n'y a pas de joueurs interdits pour
l'ensemble du système que l'on colle on
met en place
si on revient sur les doutes où les
interrogations de certaines unions
fonction du pays dans lequel on se
trouve
quels étaient les plus réticents parce
que l'initiative française pouvait leur
semblait un peu exagéré est-ce que vous
avez des exemples précis
oui nous dire quels étaient les pays qui
je crois la jce est plutôt mal merci
aujourd'hui les choses se sont
normalisés les mystères suite meilleur
général était un peu
un peu dubitatif à savenay sable et de
la france sanef en angleterre est venue
très vite derrière nous donc on a eu le
soutien de la leur à l'angleterre
et comme vous savez il ya des rivalités
importantes en matière rugbystique entre
le nord et le sud s'est toujours
traditionnel encore aujourd'hui et
nouvelle zélande australie afrique du
sud était vraiment très dubitatif sur la
façon dont on allait procéder surface on
allait pouvoir organiser ce système là
ça venait en plus dans un contexte qui
est très très heureux pas une idée
puisqu'il y avait le cio derrière et
avait bon des gens qui étaient concernés
quittez pas forcément dans cette venue
de ce territoire du sud dont il ya eu
vraiment une mauvaise humeur marqué
pendant un certain nombre de temps très
significatif donc surtout qu'on rentrait
dans le monde professionnel
ce connaissances pour jeunes et donc on
rentrait c'était l'époque où on a
commencé à travailler sur sur le secteur
professionnel on a créé c'est un
professionnel en 95 et donc les premiers
joueurs professionnels sont rentrés dans
une carrière autres tout autre moteur
rugbystique à mater rugbystique et cette
période là était une période un peu
difficile pour certaines fédérations
plus que tout de suite dans les idées
reçues six joueurs sont rentrés en
contrat avec les fédérations
vous savez dans nord-sud inverse les
cours sont en contrat avec des clubs
tant qu'on avait tous les systèmes qui
était conduit façon très différente avec
des responsabilités partagées où on
avait vraiment essayé d'établir des
règles de conduite sur les problèmes de
dopage en liaison directe avec les clubs
et les représentants des ligues et
ensuite la fédération nationale donc on
avait différents acteurs qui permettait
d'aborder la probable contre le dopage
de façon beaucoup plus organisé et
structuré
c'était pas le cas dans l'hémisphère sud
et donc il a fallu que ces fédérations
qui traitait directement à leurs joueurs
imposent ses joueurs système de règles
imposées à ses jours en se jetant d'un
certain nombre de pratiques leur
permettant d'effectuer
ces contrôles avec efficacité et avec
avec certitude sur l'application des
moyens et des objectifs que l'on défende
et donc là il ya eu de la part des
lumières sud des réticences marqué plus
que plus que celle du nord est est ce
que le passage au professionnalisme à
changer les choses en matière de
réaction l'égard de la lutte contre le
dopage
oui parce qu'on est rentré tout de suite
dans les grandes compétitions
internationales et il ya eu deux
phénomènes qui ont été qui ont été dont
le second devrait pas leur est un petit
peu tout à l'heure il ya eu deux
phénomènes qui ont marqué l'évolution en
matière de contre et 2 pages c'est
d'abord l'accélération des compétitions
internationales professionnels que ce
soit les coupes du monde que ce soit les
coupes d'europe
non c'est une compétition internationale
que ce soit les les compétitions
nationales des moins de 20 ans les coûts
du monument même temps les coûts d'une
coutume on est moins 18 ans donc on est
rentré dans des processus où toutes les
nations se rencontrent sous l'égide de
l'armée
et ça c'est un élément qui était
déterminant dans la façon dont on a
abordé des contrôles parce que sur ces
compétitions là c'est lire mais qui
manager ses contrôles quelquefois là où
le
l'ama venez sur certaines compétitions
et donc on a monté des systèmes qui ont
donné de la cohérence dans la façon
d'aborder ces sujets d'avoir abordé ce
système de fonctionnement de mécanismes
de fonctionnement de contrôle et ça a
donné une prise de conscience vis-à-vis
de la nécessité d'accomplir ces
contrôles très marquée au niveau du sud
donc aujourd'hui ces sujets se sont
stabilisés de second facteur qui a été
déterminant dans mon professionnel c'est
la circulation des joueurs et ça c'est
pas forcément encore totalement
stabilisée parce que c'est le bon côté
c'est que tout le monde d'aujourd'hui
jouent avec tout le monde il ya 35 % des
joueurs du championnat de france de
professionnels en france qui sont des
étrangers
c'est beaucoup qui arrivent avec leurs
différences qui arrivent avec leur
culture qui arrivent avec leur lors leur
façon de vivre le monde professionnel et
on a craint un moment que parce que ces
pays de santé pays n'ont pas ces
systèmes de contrôle n'ont pas les
moyens de faire ces contrôles n'ont pas
les outils pour mener ces contrôles on a
craint un moment qui appuient qui ait pu
y avoir à jean talon de tout dérapage
c'est une crainte qui existent peut-être
encore plus aujourd'hui
peut-être peut-être un petit peu moins
parce que les joueurs professionnels
qu'il arrive de ces pays sont des
joueurs aujourd'hui formés qui sont
professionnels depuis longtemps mais les
premières générations de ses joueurs ont
pu peut-être poser quelques problèmes
on n'a jamais eu d'éléments pour
démontrer pour le prouver pour attester
que certainement quelques rumeurs ici ou
là manifesté seins des craintes sur
cette possibilité qu'il y avait de voir
arriver des joueurs sans savoir
véritablement qui il est et d'où ils
venaient comment il était fort mais sur
quelle culture de devises et etc
c'est le moment aussi on a vu apparaître
des produits nouveaux de performance
énergétique
les premières critiques de performance
pour élaborer des muscles de
configuration beaucoup plus forte et
c'est donc on a eu toujours une période
un peu compliquée qui a été difficile à
aborder pendant pendant les 4 5
premières années de cette de cette
évolution là
merci jean jacques lozach notre
rapporteur bien merci merci monsieur le
président pour votre contribution à
notre commission d enquête parlementaire
d'autant plus où vous pouvez vous
appuyer à la fois sur une expérience
nationale et internationale mais je
voudrais revenir sur la dernière
question de mon collègue président sur
la véritable mutation qu'a connu le
rugby depuis une vingtaine d'années et
cette mutation vous l'avez vécu de
l'intérieur puisque vous êtes devenu
président la fédération française de
rugby en 1991 et donc vous avez vécu le
passage au professionnalisme et il s'en
est suivi un certain nombre d'éléments
qui sont quand même incontestable
tout à l'heure vous avez évoqué des
calendriers de plus en plus lourds de
plus en plus chargé mais on constate
également une arrivée quand même massive
de l'argent dans le rugby professionnel
vous l'avez rappelé une véritable
évolution morphologique des rugbymen eux
mêmes une nature de cette pratique
sportive qui est quand même devenu
beaucoup plus rudes beaucoup plus virile
1,7 venu quasiment à un sport de combat
collectif
est ce que vous croyez que ou pas que
cet environnement là et plutôt
facilitateur de produits de conduite
illicites comme la prise de produits
dopants
est ce que la pression a nettement
supérieure aujourd'hui à ce qu'elles
étaient il ya vingt ans 25 ans dans le
rugby je peux pas répondre parce que je
n'avais pas des outils des moyens
simplement mon sentiment personnel c'est
qu'on ne peut pas raisonner comme ça en
termes de globalité pas ce que c'est
c'est très difficile de pouvoir aborder
la vision professionnelle à partir
simplement de quelques références un peu
un peu général savez chaque pays vit
avec son régime de professionnels à son
échelle je prends par exemple la
nouvelle zélande australie afrique du
sud il ya en nouvelle zélande 120
joueurs professionnels à l'australie il
y en a 100 à 110 ou une centaine à peu
près une petite centaine à l'afrique du
sud je crois qu'à 140 ou 150 ces
systèmes qui sont en place dans ces pays
aujourd'hui permettent d'avoir un suivi
régulier de ses athlètes de ses joueurs
de façon très régulière
donc il est plus facile pour ces pays de
mesurer la la façon dont ses joueurs se
préparent travail s'engage dans le
métier sur le suivi des blessures parce
que quand on parle surtout de jeu c'est
surtout savez bien sûr que ça intervient
sur la manière dont on peut gérer les
temps de récupération et sur les
calendriers puisque dans ces pays a pas
de club dont il n'y a pas de compétition
de clubs dans ça diminue d'autant le nom
de match il n'y a pas cette pression
quand les joueurs de l'hémisphère nord
sur le nombre de rencontres jouées par
un joueur à l'année jusqu'à peu puisque
maintenant ça a un petit peu changé avec
l'arrivée du super fifteen là qui a
donné un peu plus de de deux matchs pour
les provinces il y avait très peu de
massa se termine avec avait à peu près
35 30 35 matches par an c'était pas
c'était pas vraiment et b normes y avait
ça se limite à ça il ya un peu plus
aujourd'hui
le cas est tout à fait différent quand
on examine les les autres les autres
pays que son imposant que je prendrais
l'exemple premier exemple c'est les fils
d il ya fidji tonga samoa où là
malheureusement il rien
il ya très peu d'outils alors la
construit on alla l'irb et on a investi
beaucoup d'argent pour créer des
systèmes de formation gré des systèmes
de contrôle créer des systèmes nationaux
c'est les pays qui sont extrêmement
difficiles parce que pas stable bon on
va fidji vous savez qu'aujourd'hui une
révolution à fidji c'est un régime
militaire qui joue qui joue qui restent
qui régit aujourd'hui le sport à fidji
et qui est devenu le président de la
fédération de rugby de fidji est un
militaire extrêmement difficile à
rentrer aujourd'hui au sein de la
fédération en de fidji c'est pas breton
qui sont qui sont dans le dopage mais ça
traduit un phénomène dans lequel la vie
sociale dans ces pays
elle tourne autour d'une valeur qui
reste encore des valeurs d'une société
fermée sur elle même
donc il ya bien des traditions qui
s'occupe joue il ya des systèmes qui
s'interrompt qui ce qu'ils sentent
qu'ils interagissent les uns avec les
autres pour lesquels étaient extrêmement
difficiles sur lesquels est un
instrument difficile d'agir
et là aussi il n'y a pas beaucoup de
matches il n'y a pas de dire très peu de
matches pour ces îliens il ya très très
peu de rencontres donc le facteur
dopants est un facteur à risque
peut-être mais qui n'est pas à mon avis
très marqués là où le danger peut
exister c'est dans l'hémisphère nord où
là on a des compétitions avant
destinations qui sont extrêmement
nombreuses entre les que vie des clubs
le championnat et les coupes d'europe et
l'ecc rencontres internationales des
pays de ces pays avec les tournois des
six nations et les tournées de juin et
de novembre donc là ça donne des
calendriers excessivement chargé alors
là dessus il peut y avoir un problème de
tentations tout cas un premier une
tentation d'utiliser un certain nombre
de deux produits peut-être
c'est pourtant c'est pour ça qu'on a mis
en place par l'irb et et parent et par
la main des contrôles répétitif sur ces
compétitions ont fait plus de contrôle
aujourd'hui dans le nord qu'on en fait
dans le sud on est beaucoup plus présent
dans des systèmes de contrôle sur les
compétitions qui se déroulent ici dans
l'hémisphère nord qu'ils ne sont dans
l'hémisphère sud on est beaucoup plus
attentif sur le risque éventuel que l'on
peut
courir avec la multiplicité des
compétitions et la façon dont on peut
intervenir de façon efficace
on a laissé quand même cette liberté
c'était un accord que j'avais pris mois
avec à l'époque serge blanco pour
augmenter le nombre de joueurs sous
contrat dans les clubs pour essayer de
faire rouler les joueurs faire des
roulements qu'ils puissent se reposer
qu'ils puissent avoir des temps de repos
des temps de récupération de façon à
pouvoir organiser des systèmes on n'a
pas pu aller jusqu'à limite à la
limitation du nombre de matches parce
qu'on nous avait ce projet de limiter le
nombre de matchs à l'année légalement je
n'ai pas droit
donc s'il n'avait pas l'accord des
peuples veulent faire donc j'ai la
liberté du travail ne permet pas une
limitation du nombre de matches a épaté
du travail s'applique dans le
l'application des règles du code du
travail
donc je ne pouvais pas limiter l'accès
au travail pour des joueurs sur une quel
que soit le nom de match où les
difficultés qui pouvait en résulter donc
on avait fait une étude juridique là
dessus et comme malheureusement je n'ai
pas pu avoir la coeur l'accord des clubs
sur 7 sur 7 rue pratique je pas pu pas
pu arriver mais je crois que là-dessus
il ya certainement
un sujet sur lequel il faut être
attentif et donc nous on a vraiment un
système très très marqué sur sur les
contrôles que l'on effectué dans ce
dance dance dans ce secteur là justement
de rendre la parole au reporter il y
aurait vraiment aucun moyen de limiter
la durée le nombre de matches on doit en
permanence tenir compte de ce que
pensent les clubs sont les clubs qui
décident si je sais que c'est bon je
prends la casquette de faire 100
française là je tu peux pas en parler
c'est pas la même règle partout pour
l'irb et donc je ne peux pas intervenir
sur les pays mais s'il ya vraiment une
règle qui est qu'est lourde des fesses
et c'est le fait que ses yeux nous ayons
la liberté de circulation des
travailleurs dans la communauté
européenne et le droit du travail qui
s'applique façon maintenant pour
constante dans l'évolution du droit
européen il n'y a qu'une clause sur
laquelle on pourrait agir il faut des
conneries travail maintenant de façon
beaucoup plus précise
c'est que vous savez depuis la corde
depuis le lac comme la présidence
française l'union européenne en 2009 à
bayonne c'était bernard laporte qui
était le premier sport l'époque on a
fait inscrire la spécificité du sport
dans le traité de l'entente et européens
donc ce terme des spécificités sport
peut l'ouvrir des perspectives à
condition qu'on trouve effectivement
maintenant en france des outils
juridiques pour avancer sur le thème de
la spécificité du sport sur la
limitation sur des raisons fondées la
santé passe pas forcément la limitation
en autant de matchs pour des raisons de
dopage parce qu'ils sont pas avérés mais
sur l'app sur la santé du joueur sur sur
la sécurité des joueurs sur les nombres
de blessures qui sont des vêtements
recensés sur peut y avoir des critères
qui méritent vraiment une étude mais
mais peut-être qu'on aurait la
possibilité juridiquement de fonder sur
la base d'une évolution du traité un
règlement permettant d'être beaucoup
plus contraignant dans la façon
d'aborder la gestion d'une saison parce
que c'est vraiment quelque chose qui
nous pénalisent considérablement
ce reporter bien monsieur le président
vous avez évoqué les les contrôler ce
que vous croyez en l'efficacité des
contrôles inopinés ce que vous avez par
exemple la certitude que dans
l'hémisphère sud les contrôles inopinés
ont ont lieu dans des conditions
satisfaisantes comme elles peuvent se
passer ici sur le continent européen
écoutez là dessus oui je crois que oui
puisque j'ai pas eu d'avis négatifs et
pas d'avis négatifs sur le sur les
contrôles dont je veux pas dire que
c'est ça ce soit ce soit mme se sont mal
passées j'ai pas eu de deux contre un
des deux gros fûts de bien quelques
refus en france on quelqu'un osait en
europe il ya eu quelques-uns aussi
l'année ses recettes mais très peu en
pourcentage par rapport à l'ensemble des
contrôles qui sont effectués donc ya pas
vraiment un sentiment de non respect de
la procédure par contre votre question
impôts même me permets d'intervenir sur
un sujet j'aimerais bien qu'on ait une
coordination beaucoup plus étroite entre
entre la mae et les fédérations
internationales sur la façon dont on
pourrait diriger des contrôles je crois
que je crois que ce serait bien que là
bas nous permettent d'avoir une
réflexion parce que bon la coupe du
monde c'est clair tout le monde vient
pour la coupe du monde la main à des
legs cesser ces contrôleurs l'afeas
hanson a les siens on est nombreux sur
le site
là dessus on fait des contrôles nombreux
variés d'accord mais par contre derrière
il n'y a pas forcément la même les mêmes
quantités de contrôle qui sont effectués
on n'a pas les mêmes disponibilités sur
les sur les compétitions n'y a pas
forcément un calendrier qui permet de
mesurer les les les interventions que
l'on peut faire au niveau de la marque
comme comme au niveau d'inflation
peut-être qu'il serait bien connue des
calendriers qui se met en place beaucoup
plus structuré d'abord se permettrait
aux gens de se connaître et d'avoir bus
confiance par rapport au sentiment que
j'exprimais tout à l'heure sur les
objectifs que l'on poursuit d'avoir
véritablement d'aider des relations qui
permet d'avoir sur le terrain une
efficacité de de présence rapprochée
parce que bien sûr des fédérations
locales nationales quand elle voit les
petits accrocs qui peuvent se passer
entre les contrôleurs de l'ama d'un côté
qui n'appliquent pas les mêmes
procédures que nous appliquons ya
il ya de temps en temps des petites
anicroches sur les procédures utilisées
mais ce que les fédérations nationales
ou les joueurs eux-mêmes les utilisent
pour dire attendez encore une fois c'est
le bazar nous emmerdent on nous
contraint et on n'est pas voilà si vous
n'êtes pas d'accord entre vous n'êtes
pas les mêmes pigments il ya de ce côté
là peut-être du travail à faire pour
qu'on puisse être beaucoup plus près de
la réalité et des objectifs que l'on
poursuit si on a des alertes si on a des
substances si on peut avoir un certain
qu'on puisse arriver à trouver des
outils qui peut être eu des swaps
arnould direct soit par l'ama je crois
qu'il peut y avoir là dessus des
éléments qui complémentaires nécessaires
nécessaire à redonner un climat serein
dans l'ensemble des contrôles qui sont
effectuées et en même temps peut-être un
peu plus près de la réalité de ce qu'on
peut craindre ou redouté sûreté sur un
territoire
dans le prolongement de la question du
rapporteur
que pensez-vous des contrôles inopinés
est ce que c'est une bonne chose ou est
ce que ce serait adapté améliorée selon
nous on a peut être tort ils sont assez
indispensable pour faire avancer la
lutte contre le dopage
donc quand pensez vous de ces contrôles
inopinés mais moi je crois que c'est
nécessaire à mon avis le contrôle en
dehors des compétitions puisque c'est
comme ça je l'appelle contrat en or du
bia le contrôle en compétition qui vit
et parfaitement
justifier sur la compétition bon quand
on leur compétition ça permet le suivi
de ce qui peut se cacher derrière ce
qu'on a vu dans d'autres disciplines sur
des opérations beaucoup plus forte dans
la manipulation génétique passe pas
génétique sanguine ou des manipulations
peut-être plus lourde sur les sur les
sur les organismes des athlètes donc là
dessus la science a montré qu'il existe
des procédés qu'il existe des techniques
les contrôles l'ont prouvé aussi qu'il y
avait des dérives résultant de ces
pratiques donc il est important qu'on
maintienne la pression sur les contrôles
hors compétition
après je crois qu'il est important de
définir ce que l'on ce que l'on peut
faire comment on peut faire je crois
qu'il faut qu'on soit dans la mesure où
c'est un contrôle qui suscite dans le
monde sportif d'une manière générale un
commentaire tiens tu arrives toi tu as
fait l'objet d'un contrôle mais pourquoi
toi et qu'est ce qui se passe et
qu'est-ce que dans le joueur se sent
déjà un peu fautif par rapport à ses
collègues c'est là c'est un sport
collectif c'est comme ça que c'est perçu
donc c'est quelque chose qui est gênant
pour le jeu pour l'athlète ses kilos il
se sent en situation de devoir se
justifier alors qu'il a été pris au
hasard alors qu'il a été pris sur un sur
voilà sur un critère tout à fait
extérieur à sa propre sa propre démarche
donc il se sent en difficulté par
rapport à ses collègues et ça s'est
passé à ses camarades de club ça c'est
embêtant
donc il faut qu'on sache comment
résoudre ça comment on peut expliquer ça
qu'il est vraiment une nécessité de
pédagogie derrière ça parce que ça crée
des systèmes s'est créé des comptes et
des sensations de 2,2 voilà de malaise
entre les entre les entre deux équipiers
ça c'est pas très bon il ya un deuxième
élément aussi kiki et qui intervient
dans system inopinés c'est que chacun se
sente concerné donc là c'est peut-être
d'éléments positifs ces comportements
ont fait un contrôle dans un club
vous êtes certains que les 40 joueurs
professionnels le savent
ça peut leur arriver les dirigeants le
savent attention on est sous
surveillance les le monde les supporters
aussi parce que les médias rapidement
sont au courant donc il ya il ya une
information qui sort dans les médias
donc un élément de communication
derrière
troll mais qu'étant une communication
qui malheureusement est basé sur
l'élément répressive ya très peu de
communication sur l'événement préventif
croix là dessus c'est quelque chose
d'important pour qu'on fasse adhérer les
gens et notamment les sportifs le monde
sportif
il faut que sa part il faut que le
contrôle qui sont effectués dans
l'équipe market circonstances soient
fasse l'objet d'une communication on
apporte quelque chose ou un soutien
quelque chose ou on confirme une volonté
de donner le meilleur d'eux quelque part
il faut qu'on soit positif ou plus que
négatif or toujours les commentaires qui
sont des vecteurs matière de dopage
aujourd'hui notamment dans les médias
puissent pas parce qu'ils sont là mais
on a des sentiments négatifs il ya
toujours des suspicions qui dès sa
travers un système de contrôle ou un
contrôle ou un résultat ou dont ça c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut à mon avis
peut-être essayer de gommer
on a besoin d'un contrôle inopiné il
faut les maintenir il faut les deux il
faut leur donner du sens il faut
redonner de la delà de la delà du
contenu pour qu'on en tire quelque chose
qui permet de continuer dans la sécurité
à faire ce qu'on doit faire
résident tout supporter vous avez évoqué
la coupe du monde de rugby et vous avez
dit les herbes et arrive avec ses
contrôleurs lama arrive avec ses
contrôleurs
ce qui n'a pas une instance de trop puis
mais c'est laquelle je me garderai bien
de dire non on a besoin de fixer on a
besoin de tout le monde il faut pas se
contraire on a toujours dit solaire
qu'on a une dizaine de nations qui sont
vraiment armés avec des agences à peu
près correct pour travailler
correctement ne l'a pas c'est donc on a
besoin d' agences nationales et plus
honorable ce sera il faut vraiment qu'on
travaille là dessus et là dessus il ya
un gros travail à faire de conviction
vis-à-vis des gouvernements
et c'est là où le rôle de la france a
encore tout son sens pour pouvoir peser
sur le gouvernement en la matière pour
qu'on continue à être à être actives
dans ce domaine là il n'y avait pas cinq
je voulais dire j'aimerais que vous
croyez pas qu'il est suffisant d'avoir
un organisme totalement indépendant du
mouvement sportif en occurrence la main
pour procéder à ces contrôles dans ce
genre de compétitions internationales
alors si c'est pas la vie tout le monde
ça sert est adresse à savoir mme ça peut
être la main c'est pas gênant ça peut
être aussi la fellation internationale
je vois pas je vois pas comment on
pourrait y voir en tout cas qu'on en
parle
moi je
je suis pas fais pas du tout opposée à
sk des systèmes qui se mettront pas son
contrat pour les recherches
mais quand qu'on puisse définir une
règle de conduite moi j'ai besoin de ça
pas ça sert à rien d'envoyer des
contrôleurs s'il ya déjà une instance
d'intérêt alors on est on est
quelquefois pas informé les fédérations
internationales on n'est pas informé sa
et à une compétition industrie on voit
arriver les en étant mieux peut-être que
c'est peut-être qu'on n'a pas être
informée je sais pas mais il faut
vraiment qu'on organise les choses il
faut vraiment qu'on sache quelles sont
les possibilités d'agir parce qu'il ya
tellement de terrain d'action
il ya tellement de pays qui sont à
contrôler tellement de joueurs qui sont
à contrôler c'est un peu idiot qu'on se
marche sur les pieds sur quelques
compétitions parce qu'elles sont majeurs
et que chacun recherche quelque chose de
fort dans ce qu en action et que d'à
côté on passe parce qu'on a plus les
moyens d'aller quelque part où il peut y
avoir d'autres intérêts peut-être plus
marquée que dans ceux là je pense qu'un
joueur aujourd'hui en coupe du monde
en rugby tout ce pas le rugby et ce
serait très compliqué un joueur venait
en coupe du monde de ceux de se doper
avant la compétition pendant la
compétition
il ya tellement de pressions qui sont
exercées
parce qu'on intervient nous avant la
compétition souvent dans les systèmes de
préparation de tout les pays qui des 20
pays qualifiés on dans les systèmes de
contrôle sur les 20 pays qualifiés pour
faire des contrôles systématiques avant
la compétition donc
donc on est dans une mode de paiement de
préparatoire l'athlète sur la
compétition en matière de dopage où il
s'est véritablement que il est là il est
là il est dans un système où il peut pas
il peut pas déroger
et comme il n'y a pas cette culture de
dopage collectif comme comme on peut la
voir dans certains sports
il n'y a pas ça chez nous ça n'existe
pas il n'y a pas cette volonté de de
tricher dans le système organisé
d'amener jamais jamais eu vent de quoi
que ce soit dans ce domaine là dont
vraiment on est dans un
on est on est dans un système où on a
besoin de savoir qui fait quoi comment
on fait quand est-ce qu'on intervient ça
ça me paraît sain paraît nécessaire
ça paraît nécessaire
j'enchaîne sur une question plus précise
parce que vous évoquez donc la
préparation est effectivement on est
très attaché au ce suivi médical des
sportifs de haut niveau mais une
situation très circonscrites
il ya un préparateur physique français
vous savez très bien monsieur camborde
qui a été mis en examen en 2011 pour je
cite importation et détention de
marchandise prohibée exercice illégal de
la profession de pharmacien et mise en
danger de la vie d'autrui
tout simplement parce que les enquêteurs
ont notamment découvert des caches et de
glen but rôles chez lui
or cette personne c'est elle qui a
entraîné les argentins pendant la coupe
du monde de rugby 2007 ce qu'on n'ait
pas le sentiment que dans certains pays
la situation la proche et moins ou plus
volontariste que dans d'autres pays
c'est ce que c'est ce que je vis tout à
l'heure ce soit à leur l'argentine a pas
de système de contrôle lors du
suffisamment efficace pour mener
véritablement une politique antidopage
dont c'est la question c'est celle là si
on veut vraiment rentrer dans un système
efficace il faut qu'on nous donne les
moyens d' amis d'avoir davantage d'
agences nationales sur le terrain c est
donner ou redonner donné c'est tout cet
outil aux fédérations pour pouvoir agir
parce que les fédérations d'elle-même
fait à s'orienter de la première a
concerné n'a pas les moyens financiers
de pouvoir peser sur un système organisé
en matière du contre le dopage
80% de ses joueurs ruby joue à
l'étranger ou savait que ce soit
l'angleterre en france en irlande dans
tout le poids professionnels vécue par
l'agente idylle et il est payé par les
clubs français anglais ou irlandais il
n'y a pas beaucoup d'argent qui passe
dans le secteur professionnel en
argentine s'est consacré à l'activité
des clubs des clubs amateurs c'est des
grands clubs à la tradition anglaise du
multisports ge pas si vous connaissez un
petit peu la façon dont ça se passe et
sa vie dans des clubs très old fashion
quoi ces cds cavale anglaise c'est pas
du tout le système professionnel qu'on
connaît ça n'existe pas il n'y a pas
cette culture de nécessité d'avoir des
contrôles imposés régulier
et structurée et ça ça ça fait partie de
la démarche sur laquelle on doit
travailler et là on a besoin de
gouvernement pour dire à l'argentine
voilà voilà quels sont les outils dont
on a besoin
l'argentine doit vous suivre dans cette
action le rôle de la france doit rester
actif dans ce domaine à mon avis c'est
très important
merci à la mairie oui monsieur le
président on a vécu ensemble qu'il faut
se dire les premiers pas de la lutte
antidopage avec la france comme
pionnière on s'aperçoit qu'aujourd'hui
on a un rôle majeur et d'ailleurs vous
le soulignez forte à propos moi je suis
heureux de vous entendre dire que vous
êtes tout à fait favorables contrôles
inopinés parce qu'on a écouté beaucoup
dans les sports collectifs en
particulier le dira oui mais on peut pas
les contrôles inopinés
parce que nous on s'est toujours on est
le contrôle inopiné
si les inopinés c'est que il peut avoir
lieu à tout moment à tout endroit parce
que on sait bien que le dopage a
beaucoup évolué et le regretté est
devenu beaucoup plus sophistiqué un
temps il suffisait de faire des
contrôles pendant les compétitions pour
être sûr de trouver celui qui est dopé
aujourd'hui on maintient les contrôles
pendant la compétition parce qu'il faut
bien maintenir puisque sur les supprimer
on pourra recommencer à se doper et que
les moyens du dopage pour le jeu de la
compétition mais on sait bien
qu'aujourd'hui on arrive à se préparer
avec ton appel de dopage retard et que
c'est même tout l'art de la matière si
j'ose dire l'art diabolique donc très
satisfait de vos visites pour les
contrôles inopinés mais c'est bien
facile puis on veut ses limites et je
crois qu'il faut pas se limiter aux
contrôles inopinés à l'esport de dans le
haut niveau il faut le faire également
chez les jeunes une façon préventive
parce que le contre inopinée à mon sens
ce doit être une action de prévention on
est pour la prévention
bien sûr n'oubliez pas si la sanction
non avant tout pour la prévention et
pour protéger la santé des sportifs
c'est des titres dvd loi antidopage en
france je crois que ça détermine bien
l'objectif mais c'est quand même bien
facile aux portes de niveau à faire les
contrôles inopinés
pendant la période de préparation
puisque si je m'abuse 12ème contre si
vous me dire si je me trompe mais je
croyais que je me trompe pas les
fédérations sont bien amenées à donner
un certain nombre de joueurs qui sont
retenus en en vue de la préparation à la
compétition
donc cela on sait tissant il est facile
de les localiser
pour faire le deuil le suivi alors
contrôles inopinés fait partie de
l'ensemble du suivi longitudinal donc ça
me paraît facile de le faire et si
beaucoup de joueurs de mystère sud
maintenant son hémisphère nord ça
permette encore plus facilement
délocaliser et ça coûte encore moins
cher pour les faire les contrôles
inopinés
donc ça me paraîtrait plus tôt une
facilité mais faut-il que les
fédérations nous aide dans ce domaine là
dans la question que vous posez ce coup
êtes d'accord pour dire que il faut un
engagement de la fédération également
des fédérations internationales bien sûr
pour aller vers ces contrôles inopinés
et deuxième question et qu'ils vont dire
c'est mon dada mais chacun a alors
pourquoi pas - les à lutter les à ut les
ailes les autorisations usage
thérapeutique dans le rugby
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire de
combien de demandes vous êtes saisis
annuellement et quel est votre sentiment
sur le fait qu' un joueur dix mois pour
disputer ma compétition il faut un
médicament
moi j'ai toujours pensé que pour faire
du sport il fallait en bonne santé
donc j'en conclus que le jour où je suis
pas en bonne santé elle fut repos
d'autant plus vous avez dit pour bien
que aujourd'hui c'est régi par le code
du travail puisque pouvaient pas limiter
le nombre de matches encore que les
fédérations peuvent bien limiter le
nombre de matchs en limitant comme c'est
fait le nombre de clubs par par
convection le top 14 en jouant un match
quand c est le top 20 merci alors cette
question c'est la hutte et j'avais
trente questions
on n'en guérit le british national passé
répondre si cette question bat bon c'est
pas la première sur les contrôles
inopinés oui oui sur une préparation
pour la coupe du monde c'est pour ça je
dis que la coupe du monde c'est bien
encadré
on a des systèmes préparatoires sur
lesquels on peut intervenir bilan avance
une autre on commence à établir une pré
liste de joueurs le mois de juillet et
la compétition le mois d'octobre donc la
nature des outils pour travailler là
dessus c'est pour ça ça pose pas
problème et quand on se marche un peu
sur les pieds écartés entre des
organismes c'est qu'on doit prévoir
pendant ces périodes là des systèmes
dans lesquels on ne peut intervenir de
façon coordonnée et qu'on sache vraiment
comment comment pas avancé mais les
contrôles oui il opiné oui ça sans
pareil ça me paraît nécessaire à la
bonne marche du dispositif sur les 1,8
et oui la la j'ai toujours eu mois saint
théodore gassion et je n'ai pas la
réponse mais mais j'aimerais bien avoir
un jour si on peut trouver pourquoi et
comment il ya de plus en plus
d'asthmatiques sur le terrain de sport
c'est un peu c'est un peu gênant alors
je ne sais pas quelles conditions est ce
que c'est sûr qu'elle sur quel sur quel
type de deux raisons on intervient sur
l'alsace mais aujourd'hui je ne sais pas
médecin mais messam interpellé sam a été
appelé en jeu j'en connais quelques-uns
quelques-uns que j'ai même interrogé
quand j'étais président a fait des jeux
des réponses
bon eh oui mais ce genre un peu embêtant
quoi donc j'aimerais savoir un peu si on
peut trouver un jour la raison qui fait
que c'est c'est un peu perturbant dans
la façon d'aborder un peu le sujet alors
s'il ya des prescriptions médicales
exercer médecin pas ses responsabilités
un séduit le médecin c'est lui qui
intervient choix de facteurs secteur
médical aussi de plus en plus présent
aujourd'hui dans les questions de dopage
on a bien vu un c ce sont des questions
qui sont extrêmement importantes et que
le rôle joué par le médecin dans un
équipe dans un dans un club et un rôle
extrêmement important dans la façon
d'aborder les problèmes de santé puisque
la partie dopage c'est la santé un qui
est en cause c'est pas le c'est pas
truqué le jeu d'abord c'est la référence
de la santé de la tête qui d'abord une
prise en considération tonga dessus nos
poilus médecins il est quand même
important est que et que le choix des
médecins doit être vraiment très très
très mesurée par les clubs j'espère
qu'ils le font tous avaient conscience
mais c'est un sujet à ut qui m'a
toujours un peu dérangé c'est clair des
présidents une autre question
c'est vrai parce que le jeu vous encore
des colonnes le jeu lui-même puis comme
tant que fédération vous êtes maître de
modifier les règles du jeu wii
or on est obligé de constater les uns
les autres que le rugby puisqu'il c'est
du rugby dont on parle aujourd'hui les
règles construira blement évolué on le
voit bien puisque aujourd'hui qu'est-ce
qu'on privilégie ce contact dans la
violence dans le contact ce qui c'est
qu'effectivement on demande des joueurs
d'avoir une autre morphologie qu'elle
était il ya quelques années et que cette
dérive morphologiques peut être aussi la
raison de deux pratiques dopantes
puisque on nous a dit que même si on
prenait des compléments pour se
développer
morphologiquement il y avait des
médicaments qui facilite et le début
la meilleure le meilleur utilisation le
meilleur rendement
si j'ose dire tu portes or quand vous
avez également dans les règles qui font
qu'on cherche plus la percute eu à la
violence quand on sait qu'à plus de
durée de temps de jeu est-ce qu'on peut
pas effectivement dire que dans une
mesure de prévention
on revoit un peu les règles mort les a
sûrement il faut faire attention à ce
qu'on dit sur les règles parce que
montferrand un baume pour l'exemple de
montferrand puisque ça se passe et qui
sont comme un référent dans des fusils
qui sont pas mal mais clover mais par
contre vous avez le même des mêmes
règles du jeu
en guise et ce qui est particulier à ce
jeu vous pouvez jouer de façon
extrêmement différentes vous pouvez
jouer comme je voulais mais ces reçus
aujourd'hui je sais pas si vous suivez
un peu le les matchs du sud qui sont sur
les sur les chaînes de télévision
françaises aujourd'hui régulièrement
tous quasiment tous les tous les jours
on a des matches rixens qui sont
retransmis le jeu est beaucoup moins axé
sur le défi physique il est axé sur la
course sur la circulation du ballon sur
la continuité des rythmes de jeu il est
moins basée sur le dépôt des fissures
lac ceux-là sur le ruck sur le mall qui
sont des actions extrêmement puissante
tous ont fait jouer la masse musculaire
à outrance donc ce sont les mêmes règles
et chaque culture de jeu est différente
dans ce monde connaît de rugby c'est un
peu cette particularité donc il m'est
difficile de peser sur les règles dans
la mesure où elles permettent à la fois
une très grande circulation du ballon et
un très grand mouvement on a des scores
qui se termine par 43 38 des grands
scores élevés avec beaucoup d c est dans
l'hémisphère nord où malheureusement on
se contente d'un jeu qui est extrêmement
bas basé sur un sur le combat sur la
lutte sur le défi et qui donne à
l'arrivée des scores extrêmement serrée
avec douze à neuf ou ou des matches où
il ya que des coups de pied de pénalité
dans les matches parce qu'il a même pas
un essai marqué c'était récemment on l'a
vu il ya pas longtemps
donc voila et ce sont les mêmes règles
donc là-dessus la règle n'est pas du
tout un élément un élément qui peut qui
peut gêner le
le dispositif du jeu mais qui est un
élément qui prime
voilà que les joueurs intègrent et que
surtout les coaches intègre en fonction
de leurs effectifs ou de leurs choix
stratégiques
c'est pas vraiment quelque chose qui
influe directement sur le dopage
merci leur avance en 20100 de l'est sans
doute pour la dernière question mais
monsieur le président peut-être leur
apportant j'avais reçu aussi maire de
massy donc je m'attache beaucoup c'est
bien avec rencontre qui avait inauguré
notre maison du rugby nous sommes et où
moi je suis arrivé en cours et je m'en
excuse mais du coup j'ai pas entendu
alors vous avez pas répondu au nombre
d'adrs à ut là tout va il y avait il y
avait une demande sur le nombre des
sucres mais pas le nombre
non mais pour ça toujours en disant est
ce que c'est c'est beaucoup ce que c'est
c'est est-ce que je vais pas pouvoir
avec un pauvre avec la fédération
française aujourd'hui je ne sais plus de
souvenirs vraiment apparemment c'était
pas quand même quelque chose de très
développée quand j'étais ça c'est
peut-être d'accentuer je ne sais pas
franchement j'ai pas de l'humeur ou vrai
pour moi mais question était plutôt
j'avais cru comprendre qu'il y avait
assez peu de contrôle dans le rugby
est-ce que vous jugez voulait peut-être
dit que c'est assez ou qu'est ce qu'il
faudrait les augmenter sensiblement
et quel est le coût du contrôle est ce
qu'il ya un problème financier derrière
est-ce que qui le supportent et comment
faire pour éventuellement augmenter un
peu le nombre de contrôles dont une wii
alors le nombre de contrôles est
effectivement on le fait que je parle
niveau international puisque j'ai pas
les chiffres de la fédération française
de rugby à deux chiffres internationaux
nous on a fait cette année en 2012
uniquement sur les métros m on est
maître de cinq compétitions en rugby
puisque vous avoir une seule chose c'est
que nous ne sommes pas maîtres de six
nations nous sommes pas maîtres des
coupes d'europe
nous sommes à mettre des tri-nations
nous ne sommes pas maîtres des
superficies ce sont des organisations
régionales locales qui ont la charge du
dispositif complet nous sommes
responsables à l'irb et que des
compétitions de la coupe du monde à sept
de la coupe du monde à à 15 des moins de
20 ans témoin de dives masculin féminin
et d'evra donc c'est notre notre système
s'arrête là donc ça il faut bien voir
aussi qu'au niveau international
j'ai du mal à faire évoluer cette
tradition britannique est très marqué
parce qu'il faut deux tiers des membres
pour faire changer le statut j'ai
malheureusement passé de 7 cette
possibilité avec moi il est très
difficile de faire évoluer les herbes et
vers une vraie fédération intentions
elle qui maîtrise l'ensemble de ces
compétitions internationales c'est paca
donc ça c'est un facteur pour moi
difficile pour vous répondre
on a fait gérable si vous tenez on a
fait un peu plus de 6000 contrôle dans
l'année 2012 et on a l'a fait 1542 hors
compétition donc 359 contrôles sanguins
donc on a une force sur uniquement vous
dit les la coupe du monde masculin
féminin n'est plus bien cet été est trop
mission internationale et une tournée
internationale
donc c'est une pression importante que
l'on met sans compter les contrôles qui
sont faits par la main directement qui
intervient sur un dispositif particulier
initié selon des critères de l'homme
dont il ya une pression rugbystique est
très marquée faut pas laisser croire
qu'on n'a pas une pression sur les
contrôles
ils sont vraiment extrêmement marqués
ils sont aussi inopinées
ils sont pas uniquement compétition qui
sont en dehors des compétitions à la
volonté vraiment de marquer le
territoire l'impression que c'est la
même chose dans les compétitions vous
maîtrisez par met par exemple en six
nations il ya que deux joueurs par max
qui sont qui sont testés voilà donc
c'est une référence codifiée par les six
nations il ya deux joueurs par match qui
sont qui sont désignés à la fin du match
et les deux joueurs sont son prix bon de
chaque équipe
c'est peut-être peut-être pas suffisant
pour peut-être investir un petit peu
plus avant pendant je sais pas trouver
des systèmes qui permettent d'avoir sur
l'équipe un nombre plus important de
joueurs qui sont qui sont assignés sur
le contrôle anti-dopage voilà ça
malheureusement on est on est pas on
n'est pas habilité à pouvoir intervenir
sur ce dispositif
je n'ai pas d'idée je sais que c'est
relativement onéreux mais je n'ai pas de
chiffres à vous donner mal au second je
peux vous les communiquer mais j'ai pas
de six films n'ont pas été communiquées
par les gens de chez moi si vous les
obtenez auprès d'eux on dirait si de vos
services oui où seraient aimable
étrangement l'occupent
s'il vous plaît là c'est vraiment la fin
pour terminer le rapporteur à nouveau
bien ce plaisir vous êtes président lee
rb mais vous êtes également depuis
quelques mois président du comité
français du sport international et vous
en félicitons merci puisque donc le
ministre des sports a décidé de donner
mouvement sportif la dimension
internationale du sport français est
l'une de vos missions c'est en
particulier de de développer la
participation française à ce que vous
appelez des projets stratégiques
internationaux est ce que vous pensez
justement que la lutte antidopage peut
pas être de ses grands projets
internationaux notamment au niveau
européen qui permettrait d'accroître le
rayonnement de la france ou bien est ce
que vous considérez cela comme une
éventuelle difficulté pour
l'organisation de grandes compétitions
internationales en france on a eu un
débat notamment concernant les jeux
olympiques de 2012
cela aurait paraît-il handicapés la
candidature de paris
je sais pas que ça qui l'a handicapé
mais ça peut être joué à la marge je
n'en sais rien en tout cas en tout cas
oui bientôt chose dans votre question la
première c'est d'abord la ministre
membre de la main donc la lave a
aujourd'hui acté par sa présence au sein
même du conseil de la main du rôle de la
france et l'a poussé sur ce dispositif
donc
donc ça c'est un point très important il
faut vraiment qu'on soutienne les
militants cette action et qu'on puisse
l'aider à marquer ce territoire pour la
france donc nous on fait partie de ce
dispositif
le comité français aujourd'hui à cette
volonté de pouvoir collaborer avec les
services de l'état sur les partis qui
appartiennent plus fondamentalement la à
la dimension politique du mené par la
ministre donc on va s'appuyer sur le sur
les actions qui sont qui sont menées par
l on va essayer de voir avec elle des
relations régulières pour voir quelles
sont les terrains sur lesquels on peut
avancer faut qu'on porte le même
discours l'idée c'est de mettre en
commun c'est ses moyens d'action c'est
pas de partir tout seul et laisser la
ministre se débrouiller parce qu'elle
est à la main au contraire c'est de
s'appuyer sur ce qui va se passer à la
main sous la dimension de la présence de
la ministre et voir comment quelles sont
ses thèmes quelles sont ces actions
quelles sont celles où derrière avec le
comité français qui va réunir l'ensemble
des autres intervenants poussé agir
travailler dans le même sens qu'on
puisse véritablement abordé ces
questions pour en faire une priorité
internationale
l'idée c'est vraiment qu'on puisse au
niveau du cio si c'est le cas je pense
qu'il ya d'autres sens p 2 seuil haut
c'est quand même là l'instance
fondamental qu'on puisse peser pour que
le rôle de la france soit un rôle
reconnu non seulement reconnu comme il
est aujourd'hui mais en même temps
efficace et acteurs de la promotion du
sport on peut pas concevoir aujourd'hui
un vecteur de sport pour dans une
promotion forte internationale
si y'a pas avec la certitude que l'on
développe des valeurs qui vante qui
vante avec développement du sport ça
fait partie véritablement de lui-même du
même outil
donc je crois que ça serait pas mal pour
le comité français c'est un axe sur
lequel on va travailler en liaison bien
évidemment avec avec la ministre est
dernière question il ne vous a pas
échappé que ce président qu'une de nos
auditions a soulevé quelques émois dans
le monde du rugby ont si ce n'est le
dopage a alors justement dans ce dans ce
face-à-face amical mais viril entre deux
anciennes première ligne est ce que vous
êtes plutôt dans la position de serge
ciment ou derrière celle de laurent
bénézech à mais déjà si mon salaire je
moi je
benzema déjà fait le coup quand j'étais
président de la fédé un jour il m'a fait
une déclaration ils passent et on
reprendra les anciens de mer de la
presse doivent savoir il ya une
déclaration de laurent bénézech là
dessus pendant un certains nombres de
deux jours il a fait une déclaration
dont j'avais convoqué bénézet j'avais
des ailes durant dix mois qu'est ce
qu'est ce qui se passe qu'est ce que tu
sais toi ben non mais je sais pas messi
mais ces rumeurs d'un jamais j'ai jamais
pu obtenir de laurent quelque chose de
précis pour faire valoir des arguments
jugés coûte laurent ça m'embête parce
que tu fais et l'écart à sion puis
reconnu à l'époque j'étais international
il était acteur il était joueur et je
leur en mai tandis que tu peux passer
des choses comme ça si t'as pas des
choses il faut dire moi je peux je suis
prêt à entendre dix mois ce qui se passe
comment et pourquoi est on va y aller on
va y aller on va faire ça jamais pu donc
je répète pour laurent ça m'embête de le
voir encore une fois comme ça parce
qu'il va pas plus loin que des secours
et si c'est pour faire des discours
autour d'une table et boire un coup
derrière je sais pas suffisant que le
dopage c'est un instinct quelque chose
de social c'est quelque chose qui touche
pas uniquement de l'athlète
c'est exhaustive au plus profond quand
je vois des des articles qui sont faits
depuis de nombreuses années sur le
dopage et j'entendis réactions dans le
blick et finalement tout le monde est
dopé qu'on soit content parce que ça ne
sont pas contrôlés ils ont ils sont pas
dopés n'ont autant autant libérer le
dopage autant les biens et encore ce
discours qui est tenu aujourd'hui
pourquoi pourquoi on fait encore des
conneries dopage alors qu'on sait très
bien qui à la marge les scientifiques
ils auront plus de pouvoir que que les
contrôles qu'on va mettre en place dans
dont je crois que c'est un vrai débat de
société c'est pas simplement
des secours et laurent bédéesque avec ce
discours il fait pas son buffet puis
fait pas c'est pas ben c'est pas bien il
faut qu'il aille plus loin s'il a
vraiment de choisir il le dit ou alors
il dit il donne des moyens pour faire
autre chose et trouver les solutions
mais pas mais pas comme ça
voilà c'est mon sentiment je peux
passionné quand et ça parce que je
trouve que c'est pas bien quoi si si si
vraiment ne présentait aucune excuse la
passion nous avons une passion moins
importante
ce que ne sommes pas en première ligne
mais nous sommes aussi me sauf une
passion tranquille à quoi il fait
allusion d'ailleurs mais j'ai pas
précisé d'où venaient les uns les autres
mais un certain nombre d'initiés
comprendront merci monsieur le président
pour aussi le prélat l'ensemble des
choses que vous nous avez dit
aujourd'hui je le dis à tout le monde et
je me permets de faire la même chose
avec vous s'il y avait des choses sur
lesquelles vous souhaiteriez revenir
nous sommes toujours prêts à recevoir un
complément écrit ça n'est pas
obligatoire mais si dans les jours qui
viennent nous de penser qu'un tel ou tel
aspect que vous auriez souhaité évoquer
et que nous n'avons pas envisagé nous
mêmes n'hésitez pas à nous en faire part
merci à vous merci chers collègues nous
reprenons nos travaux en recevant
monsieur patrice clerc ancien président
d'amaury sport organisation
je rappelle personnes qui sont dans le
public
journaliste et non journalistes qui ne
l'est pas possible de s'exprimer en
approuvant au désapprouvant ce qu' ils
entendent et je vais
deuxième temps vous demander monsieur
claire de bien vouloir
j'aurais dû dire la vérité toute la
vérité levé la main droite et jure je le
jure merci beaucoup
on me dit que vous n'auriez pas besoin
de faire une intervention liminaire
on peut si vous le souhaitez passer
directement aux questions comme vous
souhaitez peut-être en deux mots ce que
je vois ancien président que j'ai ce que
je disais à l'instant c'est la parfaite
définition de l'asb in vous savez est
donc peut-être se situe un peu ce que je
fais actuellement je suis président
d'une société qui s'appelle aussi ce
porte qui est spécialisée dans
l'organisation d'événements tout autre
domaine de la voile et de secondes
qualifie généralement de sports et
d'activités outdoor
auparavant j'ai été d'octobre 2000 à
octobre 2008 président directeur général
d'aso et j'avais commencé ma ma carrière
dans le sport en 1979 avec le tennis et
la fédération française de tennis je me
suis occupé pendant près de 21 ans de
roland garros que j'ai dirigés et l'open
de paris de tennis que j'avais eu le
plaisir de créer en fait mon entrée dans
le sport préalablement j'avais commencé
ma carrière professionnelle dans du
négoce international de matières
premières a pas grand chose à voir
dumont arrivée dans le sport a été
dictée conduite par ma passion pour le
sport pour tous les sports en fait sans
doute une frustration aussi ne pas avoir
été un sportif de haut niveau
peut-être un peu caché je me suis rendu
compte sur le tard et au delà de la
passion pour le sport c'est aussi la
passion l'intérêt plus l'intérêt que la
passion d'ailleurs pour les pour les
grand événement sportif qui m'ont
toujours ce que m'ont toujours fasciné
alors je n'ai pas de déclaration
liminaire aux préliminaires à faire de
longues mais simplement en réfléchissant
à cette audition hier je faisais là
la seule chose que j'ai peut-être envie
de dire c'est que cette question de la
lutte contre le dopage
elle est essentielle évidemment à mes
yeux mais comme comme au même titre que
toutes les luttes contre les dérives
dans le sport qu'elle s'appelle le
corruption qu'elle s'appelle
arrangements qu'elle s'appelle
manipulation de résultats
en fait toute forme de triche est certes
le le dopage il ya une dimension qui qui
s'ajoute c'est celle de la de la santé
des individus et des athlètes mais
fondamentalement si on enlève et sais
pas évidemment pas négliger affirmant
lés cette dimension de santé ce qui me
semble important et c'est un 2-2
vraiment une des choses auxquelles je
crois
c'est l'absolue nécessité de lutter
contre toute forme de triche et pas
simplement le dopage tout ce qui tout ce
qui vise à manipuler les résultats
cgg jeu je me suis posé souvent la
question de savoir quelle était doux
vient c'est à quoi tenait ce formidable
engouement pour le sport qui date qui
datent consomme au dos de 2,2 du milieu
des années soixante dix où des débuts
des années 70 et je pense qu'il ya
évidemment ce à quoi on fait souvent
référence qui est le côté
extraordinairement spectaculaire fait
pour la télévision fait pour les
nouveaux médias du sport qui était
évidemment une des causes
à l'évidence du succès du sport
planétaire
mais il ya deux 2 autres éléments qui
m'apparaissait essentiel le premier
quina c'est que je crois c'est un des
rares langage commun à notre planète
aujourd'hui il me semble que le sport
c'est aujourd'hui permet à des
populations de culture de race d'origine
de niveau social de niveau de vie
différent de pouvoir communiquer à
l'unisson et j'en vois pas beaucoup
d'autres les savons à une explication
pour lesquelles les entreprises se sont
emparés du sport comme vecteur de
communication et l'autre qui nous ramène
à notre sujet et bien c'est c'est
sûrement un des éléments essentiels à
mon sens c'est l'égalité devant une
règle je crois que ce qui marque les
esprits
consciemment ou inconsciemment des
amateurs de sport sur la planète sait
que c'est un des rares univers où est
bien on est tous placé à égalité à un
moment ou un autre devant une règle que
le sport est édictée je prends un
exemple le dans le rugby
quand la balle touche la ligne bâle est
dehors
la ligne de touche et dans le foot quand
elle touche la ligne elle est dedans
donc c'est ça paraît paradoxal mais
c'est comme ça la règle a dit dans un
cas que c'était bon dans notre cas que
c'était faux donc la règle
la règle c'est ça qu'il y aujourd'hui le
respect de la règle c'est ça qui fait à
mon avis fondamentalement une des
raisons du succès du sport vous êtes
tout le monde vous alliez petit grand
gros noir jaune blanc on vous donne une
règle et vous avez à la respecter et à
partir du moment où on enfreint cette
règle
à partir du moment où on truque cette
règle et le dopage est évidemment un des
uns des sujets qui ne peut nous
préoccuper qui doit nous préoccuper en
priorité dans ce respect des règles et
bien voulu porter atteinte à la
crédibilité du sport et je pense que si
le sport perd sa crédibilité quel que
soit le sport au bar l'agitée jean fois
parler un moment ou un autre de vélo
mais quel que soit le sport à partir de
man vous porter atteinte à sa
crédibilité
eh bien je crois que le sport en général
et le sport tel qu'il est tel qu'il
plaît à la planète entière est en grand
danger peut-être pas à court terme
peut-être pas moyen terme
mais il est à mon sens sans grand danger
parce que ça devient un gigantesque show
où justement cette égalité ou
ce moment intense qui nous fait tous
vibré où on sait que david peu bas de
goliath
et bien si on arrange les choses de
manière à ce que david ne gagne plus
jamais contre goliath
je crois que le sport est en grand
danger et il me semble peut-être c'est
un message un peu de vin d'un autre
temps et de quelqu'un qui était un
ancien et qui n'implique ni des plus
actifs mais je pense que je pense que
c'est peut-être le plus grand danger
aujourd'hui que gâte le sport c'est sa
perte de crédibilité
merci moi qui bêtement disait on
n'allait pas faire de déclaration
liminaire
je dois dire que celle que vous venez de
faire un petit personnel me convient
parfaitement
un passé à la phase de questions si vous
le voulez bien et comme d'habitude je me
retourne jean jacques lozach notre
rapporteur pour enclencher les questions
bien monsieur clair donc vous l'avez
rappelé vous avez été président
directeur général d' d'amaury sport
organisation pour la période 2000-2008
et bien évidemment c'est une période qui
nous intéresse pour ce qui concerne
notre notre mission parlementaire notre
commission puisque bien évidemment nous
avons été très marquée par l'éclatement
de la ferme seront que ces derniers mois
mais tout d'abord un petit retour sur
sur l'histoire dont vous êtes arrivé à
un sourd en 2000 vous avez succédé dans
ce groupe à jean claude killy et et à
son équipe suite une sorte de désaccords
stratégiques
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire plus
sur les raisons qui ont conduit au
départ de jean que geely et son équipe
et votre arrivée
je peux ne peux que vous dire ce que
j'ai entendu dire quand je suis arrivé
moi j'étais comme je le rappelais tout à
l'heure j'étais à l'époque
en charge de roland garros entre autres
et le je crois qu'il ya eu un désaccord
profond entre l'actionnaire à l'époque
philippe amaury et jean claude killy et
son équipe effectivement sur la manière
dont l'équipe en question souhaitait
conduire le développement d'amaury sport
organisation avec je crois aussi des
désaccords sur les sur les projets de
développement qui n'étaient pas
forcément dans le sport il ya eu
l'épisode du futuroscope qui a coïncidé
avec mon arrivée et je pense que sept à
la suite c'est période d accord il ya eu
un clash ce qu'on appelle communément un
clash est du reste entre le clash qui a
dû si ma mémoire est fidèle qui a dû
avoir lieu fin 99 et ma décision de
d'accepter la proposition du groupe
amaury qui date du mois de mai 2000 et
bien il ya eu une période de pendant
laquelle effectivement le groupe la
société sonnette n'a pas eu de deux
dirigeants maintenant sur les raisons
fondamentales du clash je dois vous
avouer que je les connais pas je n'étais
pas dans la maturité des uns et des
autres et sur les conditions de votre
départ maintenant je crois que c'est
c'est assez simple et du peu de temps
qui passait depuis donc j'ai eu le temps
de deux peut-être de d'analysé de
relativiser tout ça je pense que
c'est un choix industriel en fait en
quelque sorte il vous est un choix un
choix d'entreprise l'actionnaire voilà
je leur ai bien conscience maintenant
c'est arrivé ça m'est arrivé dans le
groupe à et sauver cette arrivée a aussi
non beaucoup d'autres sociétés notamment
de sociétés de type familial d'autres
autres cas quand la voile à
l'actionnaire tout puissant
l'actionnaire est seul décisionnaire et
dès lors que l'actionnaire décide à un
moment ou un autre que vous n'êtes plus
l'homme où la femme pour mener à bien un
tel ou telle mission qu'il considère
aujourd'hui comme prioritaires et bien
d'autres
y'a pas ya pas 36 solutions ou vous
c'est soumettre ou se démettre c'est
l'armée où vous vous pliez où il faut
partir donc en l'occurrence pour être
plus plus spécifiques
le combat qui à l'époque était un petit
peu suivi qui avait été menée entre aso
et l'union cycliste internationale sur
un certain nombre de sujets fondamentaux
pour l'avenir du vélo pas simplement
d'ailleurs lié à la lah à la lutte
contre le dopage et aux mesures qui
étaient prises mais fondamentalement à
la structure de ce sport est bien un
moment les actionnaires ont décidé que
ça n'était plus le moment de continuer
la lutte
à mes yeux c'était une erreur ce que je
pensais que elle était très bien parti
je pensais qu'elle était gagnée ou
pratiquement gagnée ou en tout cas gagné
à 90% 95% et que on allait pouvoir sans
doute reconstruire d'aider ce sport sur
des bases mon avis plus saine mais
c'était mon ça n'était que mon avis et
les actionnaires je le répète c'est je
ne peux que respecter ça c'est l'heure
c'est leur choix
ils ont considéré que que l'intérêt du
sport et sans doute l'intérêt de la
société du groupe était de 2 est bien de
d'arrêter ce ce combat je pense qu'il ya
eu aussi à l'époque beaucoup de
questions qui se sont posées sur sur la
scène internationale notamment au niveau
du comité international olympique du
coup sûr mon du comité français sûrement
aussi d'aider les autorités en place
savoir le que cette épine dans le pied
des ppte est gênante et donc voila quand
les actionnaires ont décidé de changer
de stratégie ce que je respecte est ce
que je respecte cette décision c'est là
leur leur appartient puisqu'ils sont
propriétaires de deux de leurs sociétés
eh bien mon sort était scellé bien donc
en tant que la tête de l'organisation
notamment du tour de france mais pas
simplement du tour de france mais je
reviens bien sûr sur cette grande
épreuve
on a eu je dirais des versions
différentes au cours de nos auditions
précédentes dans les relations donc
entre deux positionnements les
informations qui étaient possédés par
l'organisateur de l'événement et puis ce
qui se passait réellement sur le terrain
notamment en ce qui concerne la prise de
produits dopants entre d'un côté
monsieur prudhomme qui nous dit comme
organisateur je m'occupe uniquement du
parcours je m'occupe uniquement les
logistiques
je m'occupe uniquement les sécurités je
n'ai pas de relation avec les coureurs
et puis une position diamétralement
opposées d'un ancien ministre des sports
nous disons c'est impossible quand on
vit ensemble pendant un mois
caravane publicitaire une caravane tout
court et c'est quand on passe un mois
ensemble
il n'est pas possible d'être
parfaitement informés de ce qui se passe
on l'a vu notamment avec hamilton ce qui
se passe le soir dans les hôtels dans
les villes étapes
en ce qui concerne la prise de produits
dopants comment vous situez par rapport
à tout ça qu'est ce qui vous reste de
cette période et des informations dont
vous disposiez je pense d'abord je pense
qu'il est ça m'étonne beaucoup le jeu
n'est pas suivi les gt1 pas mal en
voyage ces derniers temps j'ai pas eu le
loisir de regarder les dites
intervention les 10 des auditions jeu
par contre je vois qu'elle me dit vous
faites allusion à quelles déclarations
celles vues dans le journal je pense que
ça c'est quelque chose qui m'étonne
beaucoup quelque chose qui m'étonne de
la part d'un ministre qui était qui
étaient en exercice il ya pas si
longtemps de méconnaître que
dans les pouvoirs de l'organisateur sont
limitées que l'organisateur et un moment
ou un autre des informations ou des
suspicions on y reviendra
mais le pouvoir de l'organisateur par
rapport à une fédération de tutelle est
incroyablement limité il n'a pas de
pouvoir de contrôle il n'a pas de
pouvoir de police il n'a pas de pouvoir
de sanction et on y reviendra aussi
j'imagine
il n'a pas le pouvoir de pouvoir non
plus sur la sélection des équipes au
décours en fait donc dire l'organisateur
peuvent faire quelque chose oui il peut
essayer de faire quelque chose je le
sais pas ce que j'ai fait pendant jezzy
pendant quatre ans du reste avec
quelques succès mais mais c'est un je
crois que c'est vraiment méconnaître
qu'elles sont dans le cadre d'une
fédération d'un rapport entre la
fédérale une fédération et un
organisateur
quels sont les vrais pouvoirs du dit
organisateurs mais je répète on aura
l'occasion d'en reparler ans qui peut
répondre plus précisément votre question
moi je me suis astreint à ce train n'est
pas innocent c'est pas nous c'est pas
une contrainte c'est un plaisir mais à
suivre le tour de france autant que je
le pouvais pourquoi parce que c'était
pas mon sport et puis ensuite parce que
c'est c'est outre le comme je vous le
disais tout à l'heure la passion que
j'ai pour tous les grands événements ça
paraît extrêmement important d'essayer
de comprendre de l'intérieur à la fois
le fonctionnement de cette incroyable
machine est également essayer de
comprendre
moi je suis arrivé chez esso début
octobre 2000 c'est à dire pratiquement
le jour où a commencé le procès dit
festina donc au baptême c'était pas mal
mais c'est donc j'avais j'avais vraiment
envie d'essayer de comprendre ce qui se
passait et c'est très compliqué dire
qu'il ya des informations qui vous
parviennent pas ce que vous pouvez
essayer de l'aigle années en tant que
que voilà nouveau débarqué dans cette
dans cet univers j'ai été nouveau pas si
longtemps que ça parce que le fait
justement d'être très présent je crois à
montrer aux uns et aux autres que je
m'intéressais au sujet je crois aussi le
fait que d'avoir tenté de mener un
combat à partir de 2003 2004 assez fort
contre le pouvoir en place a aussi
montré ma détermination à essayer de
mieux comprendre et mieux maîtriser un
certain nombre de données
mais vous avez moi je me souviens fort
bien d'avoir entendu des journalises
avoir entre 10 anciens coureurs d'avoir
entendu des gens dire m tout ça c'est
pas possible mais lui ces performances
ont surhumaine sont anormales ok oui
d'accord donc ont certes on entend ça
mais qu'est ce qui se passe derrière qu
est ce qu ils pas qu'ils contrôlent
quels sont les résultats quels sont les
deux il y avait strictement rien il ya
eu sur les sur les dernières années il
ya eu l'apparition de look like qui
faisait des je veux dire des s'est livré
à des enquêtes défi nature des
poursuites des jeux pas comment on
appelle ça des planques auprès des
hôtels mais on
je me souviens à cette époque d'un
certain nombre de 2,2 de réunion de
débriefing qu'on pouvait avoir à chaque
fois c'était des soupçons s'étaient
bienne on a vu des trucs qui nous
paraissent un peu bizarre au tour de
telle ou telle équipe
et puis mais je n'ai jamais je n'ai
jamais eu en tant que que président da
et sont présents de la tonhalle la
hes-so je n'ai jamais eu désinformation
en disant temps là on a un truc qu'est
ce qu'on fait avec ça jamais et quand il
ya eu des lieux par exemple dénommé omsa
ce qui s'est fait attraper je crois ou
le dénommé frigo sur une aire
d'autoroute le à la limite j'ai appris
en même temps que ça a été
divulguée dans la presse merci alain
dufaut merci monsieur pas dire oui mais
c'est clair deux questions si vous le
permettez une qui touche aux tours et
l'autre au tennis je vais aller un petit
peu plus loin que le rapporteur nous
avons auditionné beaucoup de gens de la
fld l' agence française de lutte contre
le dopage aussi bien des présidents que
des chefs de service laboratoires etc et
on nous a indiqué clairement mons avait
déjà un petit peu à travers la presse
que
une des difficultés majeures pour les
préleveurs s'était faite d'accéder
directement à lance armstrong
au moment où il avait avoué il voulait
le contrôler et avait toujours un
décalage de 20 à 30 minutes qui bien
évidemment en fonction des technologies
nouvelles permettaient quelquefois de
masques et je le mets entre guillemets
masque éventuellement le produit de les
produits dopants en question bon c'est
un rapport qui a été aussi rapportés par
l'usada je crois et ses difficultés bien
sûr faux c'est le contrôle moment où
vous étiez une activité aviez vous eu
connaissance de ces difficultés quelles
mesures avaient été prises dans le cas
présent et là ça me paraît difficile de
concevoir que ces retards ne puisse pas
avoir été la conséquence de complicité
alors je suis votre avis sur la dernière
phrase
mais là encore je c'est un avis
personnel
donc je suis pas sûr que ça compte
beaucoup le et qu'est ce qui se passe en
fait dans un système tel qu'il a été
conçu
je pense que le
la fédération internationale avait a été
sans doute assez en avance par rapport
aux autres fédérations sur ce problème
de la lutte contre le dopage pourquoi
parce qu'elle a été plus sévèrement
atteintes que toutes autres fédérations
avec ça remonte à la mort de tom simpson
dont les plus anciens se souviennent
mais aussi avec toutes là toute la
carrière tout ce qui toute l'histoire
qui tourne autour du dopage et du vélo
depuis depuis puis quasiment toujours et
bien sûr bien sûr est que ceux couverts
ce couronnement si je puis dire un
impitoyable de l' affaire festina
je pense qu'à ce moment là la fédération
internationale a entre autres estimé que
pour protéger son sport il fallait être
en mesure de contrôler et de comprendre
ce qui se passait et alors là c'est un
repliement aucune aucune preuve de ce
que j'avance mais il me semble que c'est
dans la nature humaine
pour une fédération quelle qu'elle soit
d'ailleurs un moment ou un autre ne pas
être sans doute la plus à même de lutter
contre un sport contre un contre un
contre le dopage dans son sport alors
même que l'image de son sport peu dé
facto être sérieusement détériorés donc
le il me semble que tout le problème
vient de là après complicité pas
complicité ce qu'on a prévenu avant est
ce que le système qui a été mise en
place par l'union cycliste
internationale à l'époque était plus un
système qui était bâti est fait pour
prévenir les équipes et prévenir les
coureurs avant en leur disant attention
les gars là vous allez trop loin au delà
de ceux de ce seuil ou au delà de ça on
va plus pouvoir
rien faire là vous allez vous allez
passer à la trappe est-ce que ça a été
ça je pense que malheureusement c'est
une conséquence possible j'ai là aussi
je n'ai aucune preuve de ce que je dis
personne ne les a à ma connaissance mais
je pense que c'est une conséquence
probable est possible de ce qui se passe
quand on confie à quelqu'un qui a une
entité fédération en l'occurrence
fédération internationale on lui confie
le pouvoir de contrôle alors que son
intérêt est sans doute qu'ils aient pas
de contrôle donc au taquet pas de
positif
ce qui évidemment mène à un autre débat
notre sujet c'est qu'il doit faire des
contrôles et qui doit qui doivent faire
c'est que sur des sanctions s'il lui
faut continuer merci ça me permet
d'enchaîner magnifiquement à ma deuxième
question puisque il s'agit de je crois
que vous avez dit que vous avez vous
étiez occupé de roland garros
on a maintenant et la fld se plaint de
ne pas avoir accès à roland garros et
les contrôles antidopage se font
uniquement sur ce grand tournoi par la
fédération internationale bon et je suis
convaincu que si la fel des pouvait
rentrer à roland-garros le tournoi et
gagnerait en crédibilité
voilà pour les travaux de la commission
d' enquête sénatoriale sur le dopage
pour revoir c'est travaux ou en savoir
plus sur cette commission denquête notre
site internet publicsenat.fr tout de
suite à l'émission politique de la
rédaction de public sénat preuve par 3
qui reçoit ce soir pierre laurent
secrétaire national du parti communiste
et sénateur de paris bonne soirée à tous